Guten Morgen Linus. Du, das Web ist gerade dreißig Jahre alt geworden.
Ja, die Mitlive-Crises hat sich ja schon länger angedeutet.
Logbuchnetzpolitik mit der Folge zweihunderteinundneunzig aufgezeichnet am vierzehnten März zweitausendneunzehn.
Live im Internet mit dem klackernden MacBook von Thomas.
Und das das Web ist dreißig Jahre alt geworden. Gestern glaube ich war das, ne? Am dreizehnten März oder wann war das? Ich ich bin gerade.
Ich glaub zwölfter Dienstag war's.
Ja, wie findest du?
Ja gut, ich meine, äh es ist nicht weggegangen und noch ist es da, aber das mit der Mitte of Christus ist schon
ernst gemeint, also so schön, dezentral ist es nicht mehr, noch ist es bunt, ähm aber vielleicht hat schon so leichte Herbst-Allüren, kommt mir hin und wieder vor.
Ich finde das auch äh also ich habe ähm an dem Tag einige Radiointerviews dazu gegeben.
Und ich war überrascht, welche Fragen die äh Journalistinnen und Journalisten gestellt haben. Ich hatte auch so meinen Sermon vorbereitet von wegen, ne,
Dezentralität und so, ne? Und jetzt seid ihr alle auf Facebook und das ist so, war das nicht gedacht und ähm die Utopie war einer anderen.
Die waren aber alle damit beschäftigt so ja äh entzweit uns das Netz, Hass im Netz, ne, das war das große Thema.
Hassmaschine, Internet war im Prinzip so das, was worüber alle sprechen wollten. Fand ich ähm.
Auch ein bisschen interessant, also fand ich interessant und überraschend. Stimmt natürlich, ist natürlich auch eine eine sehr wichtige Beobachtung, ne? Irgendwie die Idee uns wir rücken alle zusammen, das Internet bringt uns näher zueinander. Ist irgendwie auch nicht so besonders gut gealtert.
Ja, ich meine, ich habe da eine radikale Sicht, also das das Internet hat sein Versprechen erfüllt. Wir haben jetzt alle eine Stimme, wir sind alle irgendwie adressierbar und äh es gibt keine großen Geldkeeper mehr.
Haben wir den Salat.
Ja, jetzt haben die Leute halt auch alle eine Schimmel, das ist halt das, was sie sagen, ja. Ähm äh und deswegen also
Ich glaub ja Pubertät ist es sicherlich nicht mehr, aber ich glaub da kommt auch noch was. Also ähm
das äh ist auf jeden Fall noch nicht auf seinem Zenit angekommen. Ich will so optimistisch bleiben, dass da Kader auch mit guter Netzpolitik noch ähm gesellschaftlicher Verbesserungen möglich sind, an die wir heute auch noch gar nicht denken.
Aber es ist lustig, wie oft sich Tim Burneslin zwischen so einsetzt und also ich meine, der Mensch ist immer noch sehr visionär unterwegs.
Man muss auch oft Feuerwehr spielen, aber der der geht auf jeden Fall noch mit konkreten Beispielen und Projekten voran.
Äh du meinst dieses äh Solid oder äh äh.
Zum Beispiel ja, ja. Er ist ja.
Tim Benesli äh ist der Webdeveloper.
Ja, der, der, der Erfinder Sir Tim Burner.
Für mich immer noch Sir, ja? Ähm wir.
Ja, das ist äh ich ich weiß, ich habe das weiß es ganz genau, weil ich bei den ganzen Ibis an die Abgeordneten äh ist ja einer der Kritiker der Uploadfilter und da kann man immer bei den konservativen reinschauen. Surteam Burners liest auf unserer Seite.
Äh
Ähm wir schauen uns ein bisschen das Feedback an.
Ey Kinder, ihr müsst euch mal irgendwie aussprechbare Psynonyme benutzen, ja? Moorhexer oder,
Moorhexer, Moorhexer,
Zur Bundesratsinitiative. Ihr habt die ursprüngliche Fassung besprochen. In der Empfehlung der Ausschüsse sind noch Änderungen, die ich,
deutlich kritischer bewerte aus dem Text. Jetzt ist wieder so schön Gesetzesentwürfe, ist ein Traum. B, Absatz eins ist wie folgt zu ändern,
A Satz eins ist, wie folgt zu ändern. A das Wort anbietet, ist das Wort durch das Wort zugänglich macht
zu ersetzen. BBB. Die Wörter deren Zugang und Erreichbarkeit durch besondere technische Vorkehrungen beschränkt sind äh
sind zu streichen. CC, die Wörter im Sinne von Satz zwei sind's zu streichen. DD, die Wörter ermöglichen oder zu fördern, sind durch die Wörter ermöglichen, zu fördern oder zu erleichtern, zu ersetzen. EE das Wort drei
ist durch das Wort fünf zu ersetzen. Mit anderen Worten ähm das Erleichtern,
ist auch schon strafbar und die technische Zugangsbeschränkung fährt weg. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Ausweitung. Und wenn man das nämlich wenn wenn es das erleichtern, da wird es in der Formulierung natürlich dann auch relativ nah.
Ähm an überhaupt den Betrag Betrieb von Infrastrukturen, die und die aufmerksam hören, wissen ja, es ging bei der Bundesratsinitiative.
Das verbieten das Darknetz beziehungsweise das unter Strafe stellen von Angeboten, die ähm.
Im Prinzip kriminelle Handlungen ermöglichen.
Und ähm ich halte das wie gesagt für eine sehr gefährliche Initiative. Wir haben das in der letzten Folge mit
Markus schon angesprochen, ich hätte in der Folge davor oder zwei davor aber auch schon gesagt, wenn Dinge unter Strafe sind, dann äh
ermöglicht quasi der Verdacht zu dieser.
Straftat, der Verdacht, dass eine solche Straftat vorliegt, ermöglicht dann auch immer bestimmte Ermittlungsinstrumente. Und darum geht's auch glaube ich. Hier, das nämlich dann gegen Personen, die des Betriebs von Darknet Infrastrukturen.
Verdächtigt werden, dass man den dann auch mit Staatstrojaner und Telekommunikationsüberwachung und ähnlichem kommen kann. Also das.
Macht irgendwie einen unschönen Eindruck und passt nicht zu anderen Nachrichten, die wir ähm in dieser Sendung noch haben.
Ähm dann haben wir noch einen Kommentar von Tim.
Hallo, ich wollte bloß anmerken, dass ich es immer sehr schade finde, dass die meisten Möglichkeiten für politische Mitbestimmung für nicht wahlberechtigte Menschen nicht oder nur schwer möglich sind.
Klar demonstrieren kann jeder, aber bei einer Petition zählen nur Unterschriften wahlberechtigter Menschen. Und ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass meine Argumente in einer politischen Diskussion ernst genommen werden.
Unter anderem wohl, weil ich nichts sagen kann,
Dieses Thema meine Wahlentscheidung beeinflussen wird, da ich gar keine Wahlentscheidung habe. Tim, nimm dir ein Beispiel an Greta Thunberg,
Die ist auch nicht wahlberechtigt wahrscheinlich, dazu müsste sie sechzehn, ich weiß nicht, ob in Schweden mit sechzehn wählen darf, aber die hat's jetzt, die hat jetzt quasi die erste Hürde zum Friedensnobelpreis genommen.
Im Prinzip mit ein bisschen Schulschwänzen, ja? Und vielleicht äh bieten sich da für dich auch Gelegenheiten.
Aber wie siehst du das denn Thomas, Mitbestimmung? Äh also Absenkung des des Wahlberechtigten Alters.
Halte ich an sich für eine gute Sache. Ähm also ich glaube
dass man ab sechzehn durchaus schon in der Lage ist ähm sich eine Meinung zu bilden und die auch nach außen zu vertreten,
Äh ich ich äh finde aber auch, dass dafür ausreichend viel gemacht werden muss in der politischen Erziehung.
Also wirklich äh politische Bildung in den Schulen natürlich nicht parteipolitisch gefärbt, aber dass man halt einfach weiß, wie werden Gesetze gemacht, ähm was sind meine Rechte, was ist so irgendwie ein Verfassungsgefühl meines Staates und woher kommt das Ganze? Wieso haben wir uns das erstrit
also ich find das sehr schade in meiner Schule haben wir überhaupt nicht auf solche Sachen Rücksicht genommen und auch irgendwie die Geschichte hat
neunzehnfünfundvierzig aufgehört. Also da wirklich mal so hinzukommen, okay, wir haben hier eine Verfassung, die hat jemand geschrieben, der Gelsen heißt und
Das und das hat er sich dabei gedacht, dass er da irgendwie übersehen, das wären so Sachen, die die da schon helfen und.
Glaube man kann auch ohne Wahlrecht in Wirklichkeit über ganz viele Formen der Mitbestimmung ähm
sich auch zu Wort melden, ja? Das ist halt mühsam. Ähm das tun nicht viele, aber je mehr Leute das machen, umso besser sind die Entscheidungen, die in einer Demokratie gefällt werden, also,
Ähm ja, also es gibt da keine Ausreden.
Ich finde das ganz spannend. Ich habe auch nicht in Erinnerung, dass ich in Deutschland einen besonders guten Politikunterricht genossen hätte. Ähm in den USA habe ich aber guten Politikunterricht genossen
ja tatsächlich da war das war hatte ich sehr gute Politiklehrer. Also die natürlich Hardcore.
Eine irgendwie marktliberale äh republikanische US-Position vertreten, aber die konnten die wenigstens gut herleiten.
Das ist der Ifo Govermant und.
Ja, aber also der auch nicht nur, ne? Also das äh ich glaube ein Semester hatte ich da halt eine auch eine ganz gute äh stramme Kommunisten da irgendwie oder strammen Sozialisten da als als Lehrer.
Die haben schon also überhaupt einmal.
So sich die Sachen erklären zu lassen, ja. Ähm das habe ich häufig den Eindruck, dass das irgendwie bei den bei vielen Menschen.
Nicht passiert ist, ne.
Wenn man jetzt irgendwie sagt, äh Adam Smith und die wissen halt nicht, was dessen Überlegungen waren. Und äh oder eine grobe Ideen.
Des Sozialismus, ja? So diese beiden Dinge mal gegenüber zu stellen und da wurde das fand ich schon durchaus.
Sehr gut. Natürlich war immer klar, deswegen äh leben wir hier in in dieser Demokratie und deswegen ist das die beste und alles andere ist Kappes und äh so, ne?
Ähm der war natürlich auch viel Stuss dabei, aber der musste wenigstens der wurde wenigstens auch erklärt und das finde ich immer ganz gut. Wenn zugrundeliegende Erwägungen.
Erklärt werden, weil das irgendwie glaube ich den Unterschied macht zwischen Menschen, die irgendwas einfach hinnehmen.
Und Menschen, die halt irgendwie zumindest verstanden haben, warum Dinge so sind. Und dann immer noch sagen können, finde ich gut oder nicht.
Mehr Bildung, sage ich, glaube ich auch, jede zweite Sendung hier.
Okay, ähm ja wir reden von Demokratie. Wie schaut's denn in der Schweiz aus.
Schweizer Demokratie ähm wurde gerade von australischen Forschern gerettet. Ähm und zwar,
hatten wir ja auch darüber gesprochen, dass die Schweizer Post dieses ähm Evoting System da nach und nach zum Einsatz bringen möchte und.
Dann als mehr oder weniger.
PR-Gag gesagt hat, okay, wir Open Sourcen das jetzt und machen eine Inklusionstest, bei dem sie dann erstmal den größeren Teil der validen Angriffsszenarien erstmal ausgeschlossen haben
Und außerdem musste man ja quasi, bevor man da auf diese.
Bevor man quasi Zugriff bekam auf die Software, musste man irgendwie aller allerhand ähm Bedingungen zustimmen und das hat ja dann dazu geführt, dass irgendjemand das gemacht hat in den.
Quelltext einfach irgendwo veröffentlicht hat. Diesen Quelltext haben hat sich das Team um Sarah Jamie. Immer heißt die Jamie, Sarah Jamie Luis, ja. Sarah Jamie Luis angeschaut.
Und die haben ja und da habe ich gerade schon im Vorgespräch zu Thomas gesagt, das wird ungewird wahrscheinlich das erste technische Thema in Logbuch sein, wo ich gar nicht erst versuche, das im Detail zu erklären. Ähm.
Die haben festgestellt, dass das, was dieses System als Ergebnis ausweist. Eine Form von.
Ähm.
Kryptographischer Signatur hat, die die Integrität und nicht verfälschtheit des Ergebnisses.
Beweisen soll. Und sie haben dann weiter festgestellt, dass es also möglich ist.
Das Ergebnis dieser Wahl zu manipulieren und trotzdem diese.
Ähm very five äh diese Verification trotzdem dann anzeigt, dieses Wahlergebnis ist korrekt, ja? Also eine eine.
Das Angreifen angreifermodell wäre jetzt irgendwie derjenige, der dieses, der dieses System betreibt, möchte die Wahl manipulieren,
das System sollte eigentlich dafür sorgen, dass selbst der das nicht kann und sie haben aber diese Schwachstelle gefunden, in der mit der mit einem relativ komplexen, kryptografischen.
Prozesse eben.
Inkompetent umgegangen wurde, sodass er am Ende nicht effektiv ist. Und so quasi jemand in der Lage wäre, ein beliebiges oder ein manipuliertes Wahlergebnis zu veröffentlichen und.
Eingebaute Beweissystem, was verhindern soll, dass eine Manipulation stattfindet, würde trotzdem zu einem validen Ergebnis kommen. Totale Katastrophe, ja und.
Ihr zielt man daran wieder.
Dadurch, dass ich noch nicht mal versuche, das zu erklären, weil ich dieses Paper fünfzehn Seiten noch nicht ganz gelesen und verstanden habe.
Daran sieht man, auf welch äh dass das diese Debatte eben auf einem sehr hohen äh
Level stattfindet und genau da ist es schon, da geht es schon schief, ja? Wenn nur noch ähm expertisch äh äh Kryptografie-Expertinnen und Experten,
diese Probleme überhaupt erkennen
und erklären können. Und selbst der Interessierte ähm Hacker sagt, ich brauche da mal eine Stunde, um dieses PayPal zu lesen, um's vielleicht wirklich zu verstehen
dann weißt du, was das bedeutet für die Vertrauenswürdigkeit der Wahl. Dieses System ist natürlich am Ende ist es im Prinzip völlig unerheblich, ob du sowas hast oder nicht, weil selbst.
Selbst jemanden, der der das anwenden könnte, müssten wir am Ende vertrauen, weil nur ein winziger Bestandteil der Bevölkerung überhaupt verstehen würde.
Was ist wie diese Verification funktioniert und finde ich. In dem Fall haben's eben noch nicht mal die Programmierer verstanden und haben's halt auch falsch programmiert.
Aber ich meine, wie gravierend ist diese Sicherheitslucke, die hier gefunden wurde, weil ich meine der
so die die dieses Szenario mit diesem Backbound ist, dass man sagt, hier bitte Hacker kommt her und findet unsere Sicherheitslücken, der ist doch, dass man egal wie das ausgeht nachher sagen kann, jetzt ist es sich.
Entweder es wurde nichts gefunden oder es wurde was gefunden und das äh repariert man dann
ähm und ist das jetzt hier sozusagen was, wo äh man einfach nur ein Pflaster draufpickt oder wo man das Ding irgendwie anzündet und sich umdreht und.
Post hat sofort gehandelt, wie es richtig ist und hat ähm also wie es in ihrer Rolle korrekt ist. Nämlich hat am zwölften sofort eine äh Pressemitteilung herausgegeben, Fehler im Quellcode aufgedeckt,
behoben. Der von Bund und Kanton angeordnete öffentliche Inklusionstest und so weiter,
liefert erste wertvolle Ergebnisse, internationale Experten fanden einen kritischen Fehler. Dieser betrifft die universelle Verifizierbarkeit, la la, dann natürlich sofort klar, der Fehler ermöglicht es, nicht ins Evoting System einzudringen, beziehungsweise der Fehler allein ermöglicht es nicht.
Und der Code wird umgehend korrigiert werden, dies ist bereits erfolgt nächsten regulären Release wird der wird der Fix eingespielt, ne? Also sie haben quasi diese.
Haben den diese Vorlage erwartungsgemäß verwandelt. Jetzt muss man aber dazu sagen ähm.
Für das Finden dieses Fehlers bekommen die jetzt noch nicht mal einen Backbounty, weil sie sich dem äh den Bedingungen dieses Introsionstests eben nicht unterworfen haben, ja?
Also der, die kriegen jetzt noch nicht mal ihre Belohnung für das Mitspielen am Marketinggag der
Schweizer Post und es ist genau wie vorhergesagt, dass sie das eben als willkommene Vorlage nehmen daraus.
Gewinn für die, für die Post zu machen.
Ja, ich bin mir sicher, dass es für solche Sicherheitslücken auf äh Märkte gibt, wo sich da was lockrieren lässt. Ähm aber dass die das hier öffentlich gemacht haben, zeigt schon, dass sie ja eher ähm das ehrlich meinen. Ähm vielleicht
müsste man da einfach mal hergehen und dieses Paper ähm den Standard Wahlbeisitzern zeigen und das
filmen, so ein schönes Video machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob's in der Schweiz auch Wahlbeisitzer gibt, aber muss es ja.
Können Sie mal kurz erklären? Wir lesen.
Genau, genau und dann füllt man das. Ja genau und da haben sie jetzt verstanden. Vertrauen sie jetzt der Auszählung der Stimmen.
Es ist wirklich zu, es ist wirklich so bitter.
Aber du hast es richtig erklärt, also das ist ähm ja, man kann nur hoffen, dass die Debatte zu in der Schweiz auf einem Niveau geführt wird. Ähm.
Die auch wirklich den Kern des Problems erwischt. Also ich habe nur letztens, ich höre einige Schreizer äh Nachrichten, weil die vor internationale Berichterstattung außerordentlich gut sind. Und die digitale Gesellschaft Schweiz macht da auch einen guten Job
bei diesem Evoting Thema wirklich den Kern der Sache zu treffen. Aber ähm,
die, die da gibt's natürlich auch Kräfte in der Schweiz, die meinen, nein, doch wir müssen das, weil das ist ja modern.
Tja, also im Prinzip eigentlich das Thema das Feld schien ja schon verloren. Das Thema bleibt in den Medien, da machen halt die Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten in der Schweiz grade echt einfach mal einen guten Job das so hoch zu halten.
Das zu begleiten in der Form, das ist schon das ist einfach gut, wie das da gerade verläuft. Und ich höre natürlich auch die Stimmen, die.
Die kommen auch zu Wort in den Artikeln, die also sagen ey das ist ne,
das zeigt nur, dass das Schrott ist, aber es ist unerheblich. So dass das zeigt ja nur, dass die Programmierer schon selber nicht verstanden haben, was sie da machen, ja? Das ist im Prinzip der Spinnen, den man in diesen Dingen.
Geben muss, wenn du, wenn du das schon, ich meine, das wäre das der der Kernstück, das Kernstück,
Evoting Produkts ja das ist irgendwie very fivel ist und wenn du das schon verkackt hast dann.
Was wird noch verkackt Thomas.
Noch noch nichts. Ähm wir wir kommen zum Urheberrecht. Unser derzeit
größtes Thema. Ähm die Abstimmung äh über die umstrittene Urheberrechtsrichtlinie im Plenum des Europaparlaments hat ein Datum. Sie wird stattfinden. Am sechsundzwanzigsten März zweitausendneunzehn vermutlich schon
recht früh.
Am Vormittag. Ich habe mich über die eigentlich die Debatte machen wollen, weil die war eigentlich auch für den sechsundzwanzigsten geplant. Ähm also jetzt versucht man das einfach so schnell wie möglich über die Bühne zu bringen,
Ähm und äh die Abstimmung wird in Straßburg sein ähm beim beim äh regulären letzten Märzplenum und äh es.
Wirklich verdammt knapp.
Also ich glaub das kann man jetzt schon sagen dass das wirklich 'ne Kampfabstimmung sein wird. Ich glaube es werden alle politischen Parteien gespalten sein.
Also mich würde es wundern, wenn eine politische Gruppierung es schafft, wirklich alle ihre Abgeordneten da auf Linie zu bringen. Ja und umso mehr möglich.
Nochmal kurz erwähnen, dass das ja eine Besonderheit des EU-Parlaments ist, ne, dass die dass die dann nicht so sehr im Fraktionszwang leben, oder? Das, das hast du im Bundestag selten, oder? Das.
Ja, absolut. Das ist aber auch, was das Ganze so lebendig macht, weil versuch mal irgendwie im Nationalrat in Österreich oder im Deutschen Bundestag,
also da kannst du mit den einzelnen Abgeordneten reden, die schauen dich lieb an und äh nicken vielleicht noch, aber das war's. Die haben ja gar nicht die Kompetenz wirklich ihr ihr verfassungsmäßig garantiertes freies Mandat,
zu üben, ja? Also.
Ja, das, aber das, du hast Recht, die haben auch nicht die Kompetenz, das ist korrekt, ja.
Also ja, doch manche schon. Also ähm äh die Kompetenz im Sinne von ähm äh sie sie würden dann halt äh um ihren Listenplatz,
müssen sie kriegen dort irgendwie bei anderen Themen ausschuss,
zünden oder Projekten, die sie vielleicht selber politisch durchbringen wollen, keine Unterstützung der Partei mehr und ich weiß in Österreich, da gab's Fälle, wo Abgeordnete dann mal irgendwie ihr Gewissen eingeschaltet haben,
wurden nicht einmal mehr gegrüßt.
Die waren einfach nur noch so Gespenster, die da herumlaufen ähm und und ähm sozusagen wenn das stimmt wie nicht mit der Herde geht, dann stößt es die Herde aus,
das ist natürlich Gift für jede Demokratie. Ich meine, wir leisten uns jeder einzelne und jeden einzelnen Abgeordneten, damit sie.
Nur ihrem Gewissen verpflichtet für die Bevölkerung, die vertreten. Und ähm,
Im Europaparlament wird es eher noch gelebt, wobei man muss sagen, das unterscheidet sich auch bei den bei den Linken, gibt's überhaupt keine Fraktionsdisziplin, was auch bis zu dem Punkt ist, dass die Hälfte davon eigentlich gar nicht auftaucht.
Keine Disziplin bei den Linken, das ist echt immer das glei.
Fraktionsdisziplin, eigentlich auch ein schönes Wort. Ähm also ich rede jetzt nicht von der Linken, der Linke in Deutschland, sondern von Gurt, der
Familie auf europäischer Ebene. Und im umgekehrten Spektrum ist die europäische Volkspartei, also die Partei von CDU, CSU und ÖVP. Bei denen ist eigentlich noch am ehesten
scharfe Kante und alle sind auf Linie, aber auch da ist es jetzt schon so,
die es nicht schaffen, ihre Reihen zu schließen. Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt auf äh Pletscht oder so ein Neinchen dort EU schon vier oder fünf konservative Abgeordnete. Also von der europäischen Volkspartei
unterschrieben haben, dass sie gegen Artikel dreizehn Stimmen werden. Aktuell sind's hundertsechs, solche Pletges, die wir haben.
Von siebenhunderteinundfünfzig, ne? Da geht.
Fehl, genau, da fehlt noch was, wobei das sind ja natürlich auch nur die, die sich wirklich äh öffentlich committen wollen
und die stellen sich damit natürlich auch in die Auslage, also ähm wer wer dort wirklich diesen Pletsch unterschreibt, der
sich so sicher und ist sich dass er, dass das die richtige Entscheidung ist und ist sich auch sicher, dass er die nach außen vertreten will, entgegen aller Gegenwinde von,
Achselspringer,
anderen Interessensvertretungen in dem Bereich, die durchaus in einem Wahlkampfjahr überzeugende Argumente haben können gegenüber Politiker.
Ich muss an der Stelle noch ganz kurz ein ein Kommentar vorlesen, den ich so wunderschön fand, ist das ein Kommentar von Karsten. Ähm.
Schreibt, ich möchte an dieser Stelle löblich meinen Kollegen erwähnen, der zum Büro von Udo Vogt durchgestellt wurde. Udo Vogt ist äh für die NPD im Europaparlament
äh positiv daran, das Gespräch war schnell zu Ende. Udo Vogt stimmt gegen alles. Fand ich gut.
Ja, gegen Europa. Bär, böse.
Scheiße hier.
Einfach nein, gut.
Ja also äh das ist auch vielleicht so ein wichtiger Punkt. Es ist auch ganz entscheidend, äh dass die Abgeordneten,
wirklich auch anwesend sind bei der Abstimmung am sechsundzwanzigsten März. Das wirkt wie eine Banalit.
Kann aber einen großen Unterschied machen. Ähm wir haben schon mal irgendwie Abstimmungen gewonnen oder verloren, je nachdem, wo gerade irgendwelche Schnitte in Events waren, in welchem Land und dann fehlen halt irgendwie,
konservativen. Deswegen ist es auch wichtig, wer den Pletsch bei uns unterschreibt, verpflichtet sich auch anwesend zu sein. In einem Abstimmungstermin.
Sonst äh.
Sonst wird man geschämt.
Sonst sonst gilt es nicht.
Genau, also die Website wird ja auch aufzeigen, wer sein Versprechen
aufgehalten oder gebrochen hat. Und das wird eine namentliche Abstimmung. Wir wissen das. Ja, also ähm auf jeden Fall es bleiben uns noch, ein paar wenige ähm Tage
bis zu dieser Abstimmung
ähm äh uns dieses Ding mit dem Telefontool äh ja, das hat wirklich funktioniert. Das freut uns sehr, wir haben Zahlen gestern veröffentlicht. Es sind über
tausendzweihundert Anrufe gemacht wurden mit insgesamt akregiert zweiundsiebzig Stunden. Die telefoniert wurden.
Das sind wirklich nur die Stunden, wo an beiden Enden der Leitung wirklich schon geredet wurde, also wo wenn man wirklich bei uns angerufen hat oder Anruferinnerungen bekommen hat, dann irgendwie einen Tastenton gedrückt hat und dann verbunden wurde und der Abgeordnete hat,
angerufen
Und das nimmt auch schon so Dimensionen an, dass sich dann äh gerade in der SPD einige Leute beschweren über diese Menge an Anrufen und die sind ja eh im Prinzip dagegen, sie müssen sich nur noch den Text genau anschauen und äh das äh,
gar nicht, dass man jetzt hier so gestört wird in der Arbeit von diesen bösen Bürgern. Ähm das ist ganz wichtig zu sagen, also einerseits ja Protest
was bei Safety Internet
EU zur Netz seit dreißig Jahren auch gestört. Ähm wenn demonstriert wird, dann stört das auch den Verkehr. Protest darf auffallen. Das ist aus gutem Grund ein Grundrecht und da müssen wir auch drauf beharren, dass das ähm.
In die Aufmerksamkeitsschwelle,
kommen darf und gerade bei diesen Anrufen ist es ja so, jede Sekunde, die da ein Abgeordneter am Telefon verbringen muss, ist ja eine Sekunde, die jemand anderer sich genommen hat
Ähm um um an seinen gewählten Vertreter oder Vertreterin heranzutreten. Und insofern habe ich da recht wenig Verständnis dafür und es gibt einen einfachen Weg, wenn man wirklich sagt, okay, ihr habt mich überzeugt, ich will keine Anrufe mehr haben, unterschreibt den Pletsch und du.
Mehr angerufen. Das ist ganz einfach.
Okay, ganz einfach. Ähm das ist auf jeden Fall sehr erfreulich, dass das so so gut läuft. Gibt's sonst noch irgendwas in der Richtung.
Ja, es gibt noch sehr viel, also
ich glaube in der Freakshow wurde das schon erwähnt, wenn uns Menschen
Zuhören, die äh eine Firma haben oder in einer Firma äh arbeiten und da vielleicht auch was mitzureden haben, äh kann man auch als Firma noch etwas gegen Upload-Filter und Leistungsschutzrecht tun
in dem Fall kann man sich melden bei Marie at Next Cloud dot com. Die machen nämlich gerade einen offenen Brief und.
Das ist immer noch möglich bis äh zum siebzehnten März, dass man das tut
sich da dranhängt und beteiligt, das ist natürlich dann vor allem wichtig, wenn man als Unternehmen vielleicht auch Angst davor hat, in die Haftung genommen zu werden, für Dinge, die äh Nutzer auf seiner Webseite machen, also das äh greift ja schon, wenn man irgendwie eine Kommentarfunktion auf einem Blog,
Ähm und deswegen
sollten sich da auch die betroffenen Unternehmen nochmal fragen, ob sie wirklich äh diese Einschränkungen, ihre Geschäftsfreiheit haben wollen
Also das sind Argumente, die man zivilgesellschaftlich machen kann, aber ich finde das sehr gut, dass sich die Unternehmen in dem Bereich jetzt auch langsam
organisieren und das gerade eben auch mal konservative oder liberale Politiker gesagt bekommen. Äh wir
tun hier keineswegs irgendwie nur
äh Google äh eine Kette ans Bein pinken, sondern äh Google wird sich freuen am Ende, ähm dass sie die einzigen sind, die unter diesen Regularien noch äh legale Dienste in Europa anbieten können, alle anderen werden vor die Hunde gehen,
das sind Argumente, die jetzt auch langsam kommen.
Und die sind essentiell dafür, dass wir auch rechts der Mitte noch Menschen überzeugen mit Argumenten, die auch stimmen.
In diesem Gesetz auch unter Konsequenz sind, wenn das zukommt, wie es jetzt am Tisch stückt,
Ähm wie gesagt, wir haben ja einen fertig verhandeltes Triogagreamen. Hier geht's nicht mehr um, ach kümmer das nicht so oder so machen oder abschwächen. Die Zeit ist vorbei
Der Text, der jetzt abgestimmt wird, der ist ausverhandelt, wenn da ja gesagt wird, ist eins zu eins das Ge.
Also es gibt auch jetzt nur noch weil da wurde äh wurde wurde ich auch auf Mastodon gefragt, Masterdon, ne? Die die Zentrale Twitter-Alternative ähm.
Ob man über die Artikel nicht vielleicht einzeln abstimmen könnte. Nee, das geht nicht, ne? Das wäre hm, das wäre das, könnte ich mir auf jeden Fall gut vorstellen, wie der Sitz. Eins, ne, Artikel eins wollen wir nicht. Wir nehmen nur, wir nehmen nur drei, sieben
und zwölf oder so? Nee, geht nicht. Jetzt geht's nur noch komplett das Ding abzuschmettern, oder?
Details, also wenn wir gewinnen, wenn das Parlament sagt, dieser Trilog Ergebnis mehrt, wollen wir nicht, dann,
muss es natürlich auch wieder eine zweite, die es in gewohnt sein. Also dann, dann wird über einen neuen Text verhandelt, also wenn ich, wenn ich das ablehne, was jetzt schon fertig am Tisch liegt, muss ich äh dann in den nächsten Schritten auch sagen,
wie es denn stattdessen gerne hätte, ja? Und dann
Prozess endet wahrscheinlich nicht damit, wenn wir das jetzt verhindern, aber es ist mal eine klare Willensbekundung, so wollen wir's nicht
Und äh danach kann natürlich noch weiterverhandelt werden und man kann in die nächste Runde gehen, man kann irgendwie nochmal irgendwie einen Parlamentstext machen, da muss ich vielleicht wieder auch der Rat eine Meinung bilden,
dann geht man in einen neuen Trilog und dann haben wir aber wahrscheinlich schon weit nach der Europawahl äh Wiederabstimmungen, wo dieses Edwage neu er
Nistan verhandelt wird, aber da kann man sich stark ausrechnen, dass das besser sein wird, dass das eben.
Gar keinen Artikel dreizehn mehr beinhaltet oder einer, der wirklich noch eine ähm zum Beispiel Lizenzpflicht beinhaltet, dass man sagt, okay, ähm wenn du wirklich eine große, kommerzielle Plattform bist
Geld,
mit den Inhalten von anderen Leuten, dann äh musst du dich schon um faire Lizenzvereinbarungen bemühen, aber du bist nicht haftbar, wenn du jetzt bei einzelnen Inhalten vielleicht nicht solche Lizenzvereinbarungen hast,
und du brauchst deswegen dann auch keine Uploadfilter. Also diese Möglichkeiten, die gibt's ja, andere Ausschüsse im Europaparlament haben da konkrete Texte vorgelegt, die das erzielt hätten, ähm die die wollte halt vor allem Axel Voss und und andere
ähm extremistische Verhandler, sage ich mal, hören, aber es gibt ja
Kein Streit darüber ist irgendwie gehen wir vielleicht mehr zahlen soll, ähm aber dass die Abfilter sind das eigentliche Problem. Und.
Kannst natürlich dann eigentlich jeder Melle, sowohl Kommission, wie auch Parlament und Rat, können sagen, gut, wir lassen fallen. Wir wollen dieses Gesetz einfach gar nicht.
Ist auf jeden Fall ganz äh amüsant auch zu sehen, wie ähm wie dein erstes Parlament diese eine Version dort ein.
Kippt und dann kommt es wieder zurück und dann wollen sie auf einmal ihren eigenen Vorschlag nicht mehr. Das wird auf jeden Fall noch spannend. Ich finde das in dieser ganzen EU-Gesetzgebung äh tatsächlich sehr interessant, dass es immer doch nochmal weitergeht. Bisschen wie so ein Brexit, ne,
geht auch immer weiter.
Ich habe auch.
Was haben sie heute? Haben sie auch wieder was abgestimmt beim.
Ja vorhin war gerade die Verlängerung äh des das am neunundzwanzigsten März.
Wollen sie auch nicht, ne? Doch wollen sie.
Nicht ausgetreten wird. Also es wird auf jeden Fall eine Verlängerung angesucht, der die EU, aber jetzt glaube ich, noch zustimmen muss. Mich.
Mal gucken, ob die EU da.
Mich freut das, weil ich bin in London in der Woche nach Brexit und habe Hardcore spekuliert, dass äh die das noch verlängern werden. Ähm ja, Flug war billig. Ähm auf auf jeden.
Vorstellen. Vor allem wenn es eine sieben drei sieben Max war.
Ich weiß gar nicht, mit wem ich fliege. Aber ähm was, was ganz wichtig noch zu erwähnen ist, ähm eben man kann jetzt noch weiterhin anrufen, gerade die ähm,
kommende Woche vom achtzehnten März ist dafür noch sehr prädestiniert, das sind die Abgeordneten in Brüssel. Ähm, ich werd selber auch vor Ort sein, äh, mit vielen anderen Leuten
Edri hat gerade auch irgendwie die Möglichkeit, dass man sich ein Chavel-Stipendium holt, wo man die äh Reisekosten ersetzt
kommt, wenn man sich da bewirbt, kann man eben auch nächste Woche dabei sein und nochmal wirklich von Tür zu Zügel und Klinken putzen und sich Termine ausmachen mit Abgeordneten. Das ist,
auch etwas, das man tun kann, wenn man noch nicht wahlberechtigt ist
und ja wer zu Hause bleiben will hat auch keine Ausrede am dreiundzwanzigsten März wird demonstriert
zwar fast überall, also zumindest in zweiundvierzig europäischen Städten, diese Zahl ist wirklich so gerade auf die Internet Punkt Info, also in vielen vielen Städten äh
gibt es Demonstrationen, an denen ihr euch beteiligen könnt. Wir verlinken da auch noch die Webseite, wo ihr
für eure Stadt nachschauen könnt, es ist auch noch nicht zu spät selber, Dimos anzumelden oder eben wohin zu fahren.
Und äh ich bin recht optimistisch, dass da an vielen Stellen sehr viele Menschen noch auf die Straße gehen werden. Und äh jetzt ist immer noch Momentum da, dass das
das muss jetzt noch irgendwie diese fünf vor zwölf Momente müssen wir jetzt noch nutzen und all diese Momente nochmal wirklich.
An die Politik heran ins Parlament tragen, dann sehe ich eine, eine, eine wirklich reale Chance, dass wir das Ding vielleicht echt noch gewinnen können.
Aber Thomas, was denn mit dem Terror.
Ähm jetzt hat sich gerade so eine optimistische Note. Ähm es gibt äh
Ist ja immer so lustig, wenn wenn äh der ganze Sauerstoff im Raum aufgesaugt wurde von einer Sache, dann dann äh,
gibt's ja trotzdem immer noch andere Dinge, die passieren. Ähm und in der EU ist es so, dass gerade äh auch ein zweites Gesetz, in dem Upload-Filter drinnen sind, verhandelt wird, nämlich die Terrorverordnung, über die haben wir in der Vergangenheit auch schon gesprochen
das ist mehr oder weniger eine Verordnung die auch wieder Uploadfilter vorsieht, die.
Äh in diesem Fall aber wirklich für alle alle Plattformen greifen, also auch irgendwie ich weiß nicht, wenn ich ein äh
Sava irgendwie in meinem Verein habe, wo drei Leute ihre Dateien hochladen können, gefallen ich auch unter dieses Gesetz
Also jede Art von Hosting von Intermediär, der irgendwie eine Plattform bietet für andere
fällt unter dieses Gesetz und dieses Gesetz verlangt recht viele Sachen, aber kurzum, es geht halt auch darum,
dass man innerhalb von einer Stunde extremistische Inhalte löscht, dass da man selber auch eine Prüfung vornimmt und eben auch Uploadfilter,
in Artikel sechs dieser Verordnung sind vorgeschrieben, wenn man einmal schon mal touristische Inhalte hatte auf seiner Webseite und ja dieses Gesetz macht jetzt gerade seinen Weg,
die einzelnen Ausschüsse des Europaparlaments.
Baums wurde im September zweitausendachtzehn auf den Weg gebracht. Kann man sich auch im Kalender eintragen, immer im September, im Jahr vor der EU-Wahl kommt die Kommission mit diesen Gesetzen, für die sie sich eigentlich scheniert, die man aber noch schnell durchbringen will vor der Wahl. Das ist sowas
Und dieses Gesetz äh ist erst äh kürzlich äh im Inkoausschuss, dem Ausschuss für ähm den Binnenmarkt und Konsumentenschutz unter der Berichterstatterin Julia Rieder
positiv verabschiedet wurden, also ohne Uploadfilter und jetzt eben
kürzlich äh durch den Kulturausschuss mit Upload-Filter passiert und es wird noch durch den
Bürgerrechtsausschuss in Liebeausschuss gehen und dann wird's noch vor der Wahl auch im Plenum vermutlich beschlossen werden. Ähm! Und das ist auch halt auch etwas wo man ein Auge drauf haben sollte und wo wir aber auch merken
ähm ja das mit den Upload-Filtern wird halt jetzt wirklich noch in diesen paar Wochen entschieden.
Und äh wir wir haben so irgendwie zwei, zwei Torchancen hat der Gegner. Wir müssen beide abwehren,
Dann haben wir aber auch wirklich einen Strich gezogen. Dann dann glaube ich schon mit einer Kernwillensbekundung des Parlaments, dass diese Idee wir lassen da irgendwie.
Computerprogramm und und Klosters, propetäre Agritentscheiden was man noch sagen darf, was noch abgelodet werden darf. Ähm die Idee.
Können wir jetzt entweder beerdigen oder die bleibt.
Und die bleibt dann für recht viele andere Fragen der Plattformregulierung auch. Also wahrscheinlich auch wenn's drum geht irgendwie Hate Speechs oder Fake News und andere Basswords zu regulieren wir,
die Kommission wahrscheinlich auf diese Filter zurückgreifen. Ähm auch wenn die Technik das nicht leisten kann, auch wenn das falsche Vorstellung von
von Technik ist, aber äh das kann man ja trotzdem so ein Gesetz reinschreiben und deswegen ist es ganz wichtig jetzt hier diesen diesen Strich zu ziehen.
Und da auch ein Auge drauf zu haben. Ähm ich bin aber bei der Terrorverordnung ein bisschen optimistischer als beim Urheberbereich noch, dass wir das auch noch hinbekommen, aber
ich bin ja Berufsoptimist, insofern ist das mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Dann wollen wir deinen Berufsoptimismus direkt mal äh ein bisschen in seine Schranken weisen. Äh,
Wir ähm
erinnern uns alle natürlich, als wäre es gestern gewesen, wie du auf der Aktionärsversammlung der deutschen Telekom äh einen Vortrag gehalten hast, äh Stream-On ist kein Modell.
Für das Internet der Zukunft oder so, war der war der die der entscheidende Satz darin, ähm.
Stream on, das Angebot der deutschen Telekom, dass darin besteht, dass bestimmte Arten von Datenverbrauch,
nicht auf das Datenvolumen angerechnet werden, andere jedoch
schon. Insbesondere nicht dazu gehört äh sowas wie YouTube und spezifisch äh Streaming-Dienste, ne? Also es äh Stream-On ist,
denke ich beschränkt auf ähm Datenhungrige äh Musik und äh Videostreaming-Dienste.
Und macht, wenn die, wenn diese Option aktiviert ist, die Nutzung selbiger, quasi unbegrenzt, kostenlos und das ist natürlich.
Eine Ungleichbehandlung von äh Daten.
Die, was weiß ich, die Wikipedia-Seite kostet dich, aber das YouTube-Video nicht, äh, womit allerhand.
Unangenehme Effekte einhergehen. Weshalb.
Äh du ja zentral auf der europäischen Ebene dafür gekämpft hast, dass wir eine Netzneutralitätsverordnung haben gegen die so etwas verstößt. Und ähm.
Das wird jetzt äh vor Gericht geklärt und zwar hatte.
Im Dezember zweitausendsiebzehn. Die Bundesnetzagentur Auflagen erteilt für die deutsche Telekom. Spezifisch, dass sie gesagt haben, ey, dein Stream on, ne? Schön und gut, kannst du von mir aus machen, aber.
Das gilt ja nur äh in Deutschland und wir haben ja gesagt ähm
Ihr müsst gleiche Bedingungen anbieten, egal und zwar europaweit. Das heißt, wenn eure Stream-On-Kunden
im anderen europäischen Netz Roman, dann bitteschön Stream on und nicht äh Datenvolumen.
Und die deutsche Telekom hat gesagt, das geht nicht, weil.
Roaming Gigabytes, die müssen wir bezahlen und deswegen können wir das da nicht anbieten und seitdem klagen die äh regelmäßig hin und her. Ähm.
Denn die deutsche Telekom hat dann am einunddreißigsten Januar zwanzigachtzehn Klage beim Verwaltungsgericht Köln eingereicht, das hat dann mehrere Monate später am zwanzigsten November gesagt
Die Auflagen der BNA sind gültig,
Dann hat die BDA gesagt, siehst du Telekom? Sag ich doch, mach mal bitte, haben wir doch gesagt, da hat die Telekom gesagt, nee, das ist aber voll der erhebliche finanzielle Schaden, der uns da entsteht. Und jetzt hat das Oberverwaltungsgericht Köln am sechsten.
Sechsten März geurteilt.
Die Telekom darf streamen und trotzdem unverändert weiterlaufen lassen. Die Auflagen sind nicht zu erzwingen.
Bis nicht das äh also quasi.
Wenn das Oberverwaltungsgericht Köln geurteilt hat, dann werden die Auflagen erzwungen oder nicht, aber nicht vor dem Urteil.
Äh es ist es ist es ist ein Wahnsinn. Also ähm ich ich blicke ja mit einer sehr europäischen Brille auf dieses Thema und ich muss mir ech.
Bei Deutschland da, bei den ganzen Netzt, die man auf den Kopf fassen. Ähm also äh,
Stimmt alles, was du gesagt hast? Ich ich äh ändere mich sehr gut daran, äh Stream on, wurde eben,
zweitausendsiebzehn an den Start gebracht und im Mai war ich dann bei der Hauptversammlung und habe ihnen gesagt, dass das auf Datenschutzgründen aus NC drei Zinsgründen und aus Roaming-Gründen, äh so nicht geht und und klar illegal ist.
Und ganz ähnliche Produkte gibt's ja in anderen EU-Ländern auch. Also Tim Mobile hat das ja als Gruppenstrategie Vodafone auch
diese Produkte sind sehr baugleich, fast mit den exakt denselben Geschäftsbedingungen in mehreren Ländern.
Eingeführt worden und aufgrund des selben EU-Gesetzes auch geprüft worden von unterschiedlichen Regulierungsbehörden und ähm
es ist eigentlich immer dasselbe passiert, dass man gesagt hat, na warte mal, also das mit dem Roaming, das müsst ihr auf jeden Fall ändern, das mit der
Drossel, dass ihr hier irgendwie äh äh hat die Videos auf SD, äh die VD-Qualität herunter, drosselt, das geht auch auf gar keinen Fall. Und daran haben sich auch alle gehalten und das war innerhalb von wenigen Wochen oder Monaten in jedem Land gelöst, ja.
April zweitausendsiebzehn, wir haben heute März zweitausendneunzehn, ja? Es hat schon mal irgendwie die Bundesnetzagentur hat bis Dezember zweitausendsiebzehn gebraucht.
Selber eine Entscheidung zu fällen. Was ist im Dezember zweitausendsiebzehn passiert? Ähm,
in in den USA wurde Netzentralität abgeschafft von Donald Trump.
Diesen Windschatten hat die Bundesnetzagentur gebraucht, um sich überhaupt zu trauen gegen die große deutsche Telekom ein bisschen was zu machen.
In Österreich hat so eine Entscheidung von der österreichischen Religionsbehörde RTR gegen Telekom Austria, auch den Staatskonzern.
Ein Monat gedauert. In Deutschland waren's neun.
Ähm und obwohl man dann eben diese halbherzige Entscheidung gefällt hat, die das selber gar nicht angreift, sondern nur die Drossel und das Roaming, die ganz offensichtlichen Rechtsfälle.
Das ist dann trotzdem aufgrund der Wirren des deutschen Rechtssystems und der wahrscheinlich auf Mulius gesagt worden aufgrund von Asylverfahren überlasteten Verwaltungsgerichten sehr lange anhängig gewesen, obwohl es ein Eilverfahren war.
Und äh ja,
jetzt, obwohl's eigentlich ganz klar war, Eilverfahren ist vorbei, du musst das jetzt umsetzen. Die Bundesnetzagentur hätte auch schon längst irgendwie neue Strafen erlassen können oder sogar pro Tag irgendwie noch mehr Strafen, die fällig werden. Das hat sie alles nicht gemacht
sondern man ist einfach in Köln zum Gericht gegangen und das hat wirklich mit.
Erheblichen wirtschaftlichen Schaden. Für eine Rechtsverletzung, die überall sonst sofort abgestellt würde, dass weiter hinten angestellt. Und das ist, das ist also da greife ich mir wirklich im Kopf, weil ich meine, ich habe,
Prostitaler meines Lebens dafür aufgewendet da irgendwie mitzuhelfen, dass wir eine Zentralität in Europa haben. Und dann zu sehen, wie dieses Gesetz mit Füßen getreten wird. Das ist schon ein.
Absoluter Wahnsinn
Und deswegen äh tue ich jetzt auch äh einen anderen Wahnsinn wieder, äh den den ich äh äh eigentlich nicht vorhatte, äh weil wir haben gerade darüber geredet, wie dicht der März ist und wie viele noch passieren wird und
ja
Aber es macht ja sonst keiner, deswegen werde ich am achtundzwanzigsten März bei der nächsten Telekom Hauptversammlung äh wieder eine Rede halten in Bonn. Ähm und ich weiß noch nicht, was ich sagen werde, aber.
Wer irgendwie in Bonn oder in Köln oder in der Gegend ist, kann sich äh gerne gerne melden bei mir auf Twitter. Es gibt noch keinen wirklichen Plan, werde ich eigentlich mit.
Es gibt noch Aktien oder.
Sind, also ich habe äh habe ich das hier eigentlich erzählt, dieser dieser fantastische Verein, der es mir überhaupt möglich macht als äh dreckigen Aktivisten.
Die die sind wirklich toll. Also ich mein die machen das bei der Telekom aber die machen das auch bei irgendwelchen Waffenkonzernen oder bei irgendwelchen weiß nicht,
Bergbaukonzernen, die auf,
demonstrierende Gewerkschafter schießen und bringen dann die Überlebenden von solchen Massakern auf, die Hauptversammlung dieser Konzerne und geben ihnen eine Stimme. Äh die machen wirklich einen coolen Scheiß. Ähm
wir verlinken die und die ähm ermöglichen mir da nochmal hinzukommen und eben mit in vielen Aktien,
die sie in dem Bereich haben, äh hat man dann eben nach deutschen Aktienrecht auch ein Stimmrech
und das hoffen wir zu nutzen, um da einfach nochmal ähm ja diese Argumente auch darzulegen, weil ich, ich halte es für absolut unglaubwürdig, dass eine deutsche Telekom sich als pro-europäischen Konzern darstellt, was sie sehr gerne t,
wenn sie,
sehenden Auges, europäische Gesetze mit Füße tritt und wenn sie, wenn sie auch wirklich sich so nicht an den Rechtsstaat hält, weil ähm das ist eine mutwillige Verschlechterung äh der Dienstequalität jeder andere Konzern.
Jeder andere Telekom Konzern in Europa hat das mit dem Roaming den Leuten schon freigestellt weil das verdammt nochmal zu Europa dazu gehört, dass wir nicht an der Grenze auf unser Handy schauen müssen und alles teurer wird.
Und auch die die Apps und die Dienste haben natürlich auch ein Recht, irgendwie nicht äh in in deutschen Netzen auf ein zwanzigstel ihrer Qualität gedrosselt zu werden
Ähm und äh das sind halt Dinge, die sich dieser Konzern rausnimmt,
die ja auch in anderen Ländern nicht durchbekommt, also auch die Mobile hat in anderen EU-Ländern weitaus weniger Möglichkeiten mit solchen Schweinereien davonzukommen. Das ist nur in Deutschland möglich, weil es dieses ungesunde Nahe Verhältnis ähm mit
mit gewissen Regierungsinstitutionen gibt und natürlich auch viel mehr Lobbyisten in Deutschland beschäftigt werden, also in anderen Ländern. Ähm
und ja da das das versuche ich wieder in irgendeine kompakte Form zu bringen ähm die die Leute verstehen und ja,
Wirklichkeit muss sich da politisch was ändern.
Wo sich auch mal was ändern müsste, wäre an meiner Bandbreite.
Ich weiß nicht genau wie das mit deiner Bandbreite ist, aber unser nächstes Thema betrifft eine Bandbreitenstudie der BNA und ich habe.
Ohne die gelesen zu haben, nicht die Vermutung, dass da besonders hohe Bandbreiten drin vork.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Ähm also es ist wieder mal eine neue äh Studie rausgekommen, also
Netzagentur ähm veröffentlicht die jedes Jahr, wo ähm eben über die ähm die die real erzielten Internetgeschwindigkeiten in Deutschland.
Das gibt da ja die Breitbandmessung, ein äh Tool der Bundesnetzagentur, über das man seine Internetgeschwindigkeit zu Hause und auch Mobiltelefonen messen kann und äh diese Messergebnisse fließen in einen Open-Deta-Pool,
die Bundesnetzagentur dann ihren Bericht erstellt, äh die
messen vielleicht doch noch irgendwie selber an manchen Eckpunkten, aber man kann da sozusagen auch selber ähm beisteuern, vor allem wenn man Probleme hat oder unzufrieden ist mit seinem Internetanschluss sollte man diese Breitbandmessung auch verwenden
Und ja, also was was da aber eben auch rauskommt, zunehmend ist
dass die die Qualität in Deutschland gleichbleibend schlecht ist. Äh vor allem eben.
Das das ist schon mal gut. Alles andere wird schlechter hier. Ich ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, dass du da so weißt du, wenn das einfach nur gleich schlecht bleibt, dann ist schon mal.
Ja, aber du weißt schon so.
Weniger schlecht ist besser.
So irgendwie so der der Bedarf der Steiger schon eher
potentiell und wenn ich da weiter versuche mit Kupfer äh irgendwie die die letzte äh Welle noch totzureiten, dann wird das Problem auch nur,
Schlechte, also wenn ich stehen bleibe, fahre ich trotzdem weiter nach hinten, wenn alle anderen nach vorne laufen. Ähm.
Und äh ja, also insgesamt äh sehen wir,
dass auch äh die selben Probleme sind, äh wie seit fast dreißig Jahren und ähm da, solange man da nicht in den Netzausbau investiert, wird's nicht besser, aber der Kern dieser Studie war einfach.
Vor allem auch die vertraglich garantierten Bandbreiten nicht eingehalten werden. Das wird oft übersehen, aber die Netzzentralität in Europa hat auch das Recht für
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher geschaffen, dass man äh in seinem Internetvertrag zumindest im Festnetz äh nicht nur eine bis zu.
Vierhundert Zahl genannt bekommt, äh sondern dass man wirklich für Upload und Download
Minimum, Durchschnitt und Maximumbandbreiten genannt bekommt äh und dass die dann auch eingehalten werden. Das ist ansonsten eben äh kein vertragsformes Produkt, ja? Dann irgendwie, das ist ja fast
Wenn man ein Auto kauft, wo irgendwie eine gewisse Abgaswert festgesetzt ist und dann hält sich das Auto dann nicht dran. Das kann doch nicht sein. Ähm.
Das können wir in Deutschland auch.
Also das ist ja aber die Zahlen dieser Studie sagen eben, dass gerade mal knapp dreizehn Prozent der Nutzer die vertraglich vereinbarten maximalen Datenübertragungsraten bekommen,
fast dreißig Prozent müssen sich mit weniger als der Hälfte begnügen. Die in den letzten Jahren ist es nochmal schöner von der Fahrzeug-BV zusammengefasst worden der letzten Studie.
Gipsloskop ähm zwei Drittel.
Nicht mal die Hälfte von dem bekommen, was vertraglich als Maximum zugesichert wurde. Und da da sieht man schon, es gibt eine enorme Diskrepanz zwischen dem, was vertraglich versprochen wird und was ich
aktuell wirklich erzielen kann. Und das ist das ist deswegen wieder ein politisches Thema, weil eigentlich sieht die EU-Verordnung zur Netzautalität vor, dass man dann nationale Regeln macht, äh wie die Leute aus diesen Verträgen rauskommen,
die zahlen ja für etwas, das nicht geliefert wird,
Und dann, wenn du irgendwie was nicht du bestellst ein Doppelbett und bekommst nur irgendwie eine Kinderwiege. Ja gut, dann schick das Ding zurück und du kriegst das Geld auch wieder.
Das sollte auch im im Telekombereich so sein, in anderen Ländern ist es auch so, nur in Deutschland hat sich da,
Das zuständige Wirtschaftsministerium nicht durchbürungen, ein äh Transparenzverordnung zu machen, die dem auch genüge tut, weil eigentlich äh will da will man da so einen Sonderkündigungsrecht haben, dass man aus diese,
Nur ein Compliant-Verträgen auch herauskommen kann.
Das Problem in Deutschland ist im Prinzip
Du kriegst das Telekom ja eh du kriegst das Internet ja eh nur über dieses eine Kupferkabel von der deutschen Telekom,
dass du im Zweifelsfall, wenn es jetzt wirklich an der letzten Meile liegt, dann kriegst du von jemand anderes auch kein besseres Netz, ne. Ähm nichtsdestotrotz ist es ohnehin was den Wettbewerb belebt
ist natürlich kürzere Vertragshochzeiten, Sonderkündigungsrechte und und und wäre alles sehr, sehr schön. Genau deswegen haben wir es auch nicht, ne.
Ihr habt da ja im im Pot
Logbuch glaube ich auch äh über diese Cero-Rating-Aspekte gesprochen. Da ist noch viel mehr drin. Wir haben wirklich alle achthundert Seiten äh jährliche Berichte von Regulierungsbehörden analysiert,
auch alle Entscheidungen in dem Bereich und es gib
äh da wirklich einige schöne Musterbeispiele, wie es gehen könnte ähm und äh gerade ein Thema, das mir sonderlich, das mir wirklich große Sorgen macht, ist.
Ähm diese Regulierungsbehörden müssen eigentlich auch darüber berichten, wie sich das Internet so entwickelt in diesem Land. Also ähm wird,
so wie du vorher gesagt hast, ist das ewig gleich geblieben oder steigen die Bandbreiten in diesem Land? Das kann man ja messen. Kann sich ja anschauen irgendwie,
wird so in Summe ähm die Geschwindigkeit, mit der da, dass das Internet an die Haushalte geströmt wird, wird die insgesamt schneller oder stagniert hier oder geht die vielleicht sogar zurück und äh da,
leider verdammt wenig Regulierungsbehörden, also nur acht von einunddreißig die diese Zahlen wirklich veröffentlichen, die wirklich sagen, hey, so geht's dem Internet bei uns und das wird wenigstens von Jahr zu Jahr besser. Man kann da immer noch über,
Trosseln und Verkehrsmanagement und Sirrating streiten, aber das wenigstens der,
die die verfügbare Bandbreite so weit steigt, dass man mit dem steigenden Bedarf mithalten kann
das ist wirklich so ein Thema wie äh was nicht Stromnetz das auch mithalten muss mit äh steigenden Belastungen. Und äh da zu investieren äh bringt viel, weil wenn's da mal einen Kollaps gi
dann haben wir ernsthafte Probleme. Ja nur so viel dazu.
Apropos Kollaps, wen würdet ihr rufen in Österreich, wenn's zum Kollaps kommt, das Militär.
Ja, das Mädchen besser. Ich denke da immer so an äh das ist ein lustiges Thema. Militär in Österreich ist eigentlich lustig
also zumindest für mich als Zivildiener. Äh ich verbinde da eigentlich nur schlechte Witze und ja vielleicht Katastrophenhilfe noch damit. Ähm
aber ja, wir wir haben ja in Österreich eine eine ähm.
Äh rechte Regierung, also die ÖVP und die FPÖ, was bei euch die AfD ist und die CDU regieren in Österreich gerade und äh,
gibt es ganz viele Gesetze, ich will jetzt nur eines rausgreifen, nämlich das Wehrrechtsänderungsgesetz. Ähm.
Dass gerade in einem Eiltempo durchs Parlament gepeitscht wird. Und ja in diesem
werden neue Militärbefugnisse geschaffen. Ähm und
äh diese Befugnisse sind teilweise so ein Anhalterecht, also dass zum Beispiel das Militär, wenn's irgendwelche Paraden macht ähm und da kommt dann jemand vorbei und irgendwie mit so einem Schild
Wir wollen Frieden, Militärs Scheiße, dann durften die davor nichts machen. Das hat sie wahnsinnig gestört. Ähm ja genau.
Obwohl die Knarren haben, ne? Das ist natürlich auch ärger.
Panzer stehen, da steht irgendein Friedensaktivisten, die dürfen nichts machen.
Jetzt kommt das so eine Hippie an und du kannst noch nicht.
Genau, du musst in die Polizei rufen, das ist ja total entwürdigend, dass das genau das schränk.
Nee, das geht so nicht.
Einsatzfähigkeit des Bundestages einwenden, die beleidigt werden und sich nicht wehren dürfen. Das.
Vor allem haben die ja auch gelernt, wie man mit Leuten umgeht, die nicht äh die sich nicht.
Also das das Deskalationstraining in der Grundwehrausbildung ist legendär, ja?
Ja, die wurden ja auch äh darauf geschult, äh Staatsfeinde zu bekämpfen. Ne, und da steht einer.
Ich bin mir ganz sicher, dass äh ja
Also genau deswegen hat das Verteidigungsministerium in Österreich ein Gesetz vorgeschlagen. Das Wehrechs-Änderungsgesetz mit dem äh eigentlich so ein Anhalterecht äh festgesetzt wird und eben auch die
Identitätsfeststellung von diesen bösen Friedensaktivisten. Was natürlich 'ne klare Vermischung ist von.
Von Polizei und Militär. Also ihr macht euch jetzt wieder so eine Militärpolizei, so eine.
So ein bissel die Absicht ähm und das war im ersten Entwurf dieses Gesetzes äh drinnen, gab.
Ganz viel Aufregung über diesen Punkt. Ähm und jetzt ist so, also die Begutachtung ist vorbei, man hat irgendwie Berichte gehabt und dann ist das rausgestrichen worden. Der Punkt ist fallen gelassen worden.
Und das ist eigentlich viel spannendere ist, was alles sonst noch drin steht. Ich habe inzwischen die Theorie, das hat man bewusst da reingeschrieben, dass.
Ganze Kritik sich auf dieses absurde Ding f
Und die anderen Sachen hinten irgendwie überfallen aus der Berichterstattung. Was auch großteils passiert ist. Ähm also weil's dann nämlich
noch drinnen ist die Observation mit technischen Mitteln, also ganz viel auch ähm Überwachung. Es ist ein sehr breitgefasstes Gesetz, also es ist überhaupt,
geregelt, was konkret hierfür Überwachungsmethoden legalisiert werden sollen, steht einfach nur irgendwie obsovation mit technischen Mitteln drin. Ähm, Zugriff auf,
von Internetprovider
Also man will auch zugreifen können auf IP-Adressen, auf die Stammdaten, also wer ist hinter jetzt einer IP-Adresse, gerade online unterwegs und eben auch Standortdaten
was ganz sensible Daten sind. Das Mobilfunknetz weiß, wo wir uns aufhalten und das recht lange
auch ohne Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh ist in dem Mobilfunknetzen auch aus Abrechnungszwecken oft sehr lange bekannt, wo sich jemand aufgehalten.
Die müssen ja wissen, wo das Handy läuten soll und äh dass das Militär da drauf Zugriff
kommt, ist absolut irrsinnig. Das sind auch alles Befugnisse, wo kein Richter draufschaut, wo es keinen Richtervorbehalt gibt,
Und nicht mal echt Nutzbeauftragte, das ist so ein äh österreichisches Unikum, das eben äh eine Person, die sehr honorig ist, im Ministerium. Die schaut da drauf, bei dem Polizei ist es so, dass die eigentlich auch wirklich genehmigen muss. Da muss man das vorlegen und die sagt dann, na,
denen aber vielleicht nicht überwachen oder weswegen eigentlich so nachfragt und kontrolliert. Hier ist es nur so, dass man denen im Nachhinein Bescheid geben muss. Wenn man's gemacht hat. Ähm und die können dann einen Bericht schreiben, wo sie sagen, äh es ist irgendwie b.
Aber,
Über die einzelnen Fälle darf nicht berichtet werden. Also äh hier ist der Rechtsschutz sehr desaströs und äh es wird auch eben wirklich der der direkte Zug geschaffen, dass das Militär eben auch,
bei den Internetprovidern sich meldet und dort die Daten abfragen kann. Wir haben in Österreich eigentlich so ein Instrument der Durchlaufstelle,
die eben als Firewall ist, damit nicht irgendwer bei dem Provider anruft und so. Hallo, hier ist die Polizei. Ich brauche jetzt die Daten zu der P-Adresse, sondern ähm und das war jetzt ein bayerischer Direkt, das tut mir leid. Ähm und.
Ich bin so.
Mir aufgefallen, ja.
Äh aber auf jeden Fall da ist jetzt eben auch die Möglichkeit geschaffen, dass die äh militärischen Organe und wir haben ja auch zwei militärische Geheimdienste.
Ihres Abwehramt und Heres Nachrichtenamt eben direkt beim Provider Einreiten
können. Diese äh Geheimdienste haben auch die Kompetenz zur erweiterten Weitergabe von Daten an andere Behörden und Dienste.
Überhaupt nicht definiert, was konkret.
Wer sich da um den Rechtsschutz kümmert, aber sozusagen die alte Geheimdienstdaten äh äh Tauschgeschichte, dass man einfach du überwachst meine Bevölkerung, ich überwache deine Bevölkerung. Danach teilen wir einfach
Ähm und äh ja.
Die die eigentlich lustige Sache äh und ich hoffe, dass darüber jemand lachen kann, ist Österreich hat das kürzeste Cybersicherheitsgesetz der Welt
erlassen. Also
Du hast Linus in diesem Podcast schon ganz oft über Cybersicherheitsgesetz in Deutschland debattiert, über Hackback, über diese offensiven Kapazitäten, die sich der Staat jetzt zunehmend aneignet, um
in dem
der fünften Domäne des Militärs, dem Cyber aktiv zu werden. Wir haben Landstreitkräfte, wir haben Wasserstreitkräfte, Flugzeug, Weltraum, jetzt auch Cyber und wir müssen aufrüst
All das ist in Österreich sehr elegant gelöst worden
In diesem Gesetz, was noch nicht beschlossen ist, aber eben jetzt gerade schon als Regierungsvorlage ins Parlament geht. Im Paragraph siebzehn steht.
Militärische Organe im Wachdienst dürfen unmittelbare Zwangsgewalt ausüben durch und jetzt eine Aufzerrung. Äh erster Punkt
körperliche Gewalt, in Form unmittelbarer körperlicher Einwirkung auf Personen und Sau. Zweiter Punkt
Hilfsmittel der körperlichen Gewalt einschließlich technischer Sperren und Diensthunde. Dritter Punkt
dienstlich zugelassene Waffen und vierter Punkt sonstige Waffen sowie Mittel deren Wirkung der einer Waffe gleichkommt, sofern eine geeignete erscheinende Waffe nach sie verdreien nicht zur Verfügung steht. Also du darfst auch den Hammer nehmen um jemanden auf den Kopf zu hauen,
unter Punkt zwei Hilfsmittel der körperlichen Gewalt einschließlich technischer Sperren und Diensthunde wird einfach eingefügt nach Diensthunde.
Sowie Computersysteme.
Das war's. Das das ist der Hackback in Österreich.
Ähm man man hat hier einfach sowie Computersysteme. Äh hinzugefügt und damit äh die die,
Zwangsaus die Zwangsgewaltausübung ähm militärische Organe äh eben auch auf das Internet ausgewei
Ähm, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das gemeint, dass man mit dem Hund und dem Computer in der Hand auf Leute einhauen darf, aber ich befürchte eher, dass es so gemeint ist das auch. Ähm über Titusatta
oder eben Bundestrojaner, Spielsoftware, Schadsoftware, ähm, versucht wird auf andere Ziele.
Ich finde alleine
Ich finde allein dieses Wort so geil. Hilfsmittel der körperlichen Gewalt, ja? Militärische Organe im Wachdienst dürfen unmittelbare Zwangsgewalt ausüben durch Hilfsmittel der körperlichen Gewalt einschließlich.
Technischer.
Sperren und Diensthunde sowie Computersysteme. Diensthunde sowie Computersysteme, also Dienst, Hunddienst, Handy und dann hast du schon hast du deine geheim.
Ja, also den den militärischen Hacker erkennt man am Hund.
Ähm ja äh es ist es ist eigentlich nicht mehr viel zu so zu sagen. Also dieses Gesetz ist eben ein Tempo. Man hat irgendwie nicht mal die Begutachtung abgewartet. Wir haben brav unsere Stellungnahme.
Nein, nein, es ist jetzt noch.
Beschlossen.
Genau, also ähm.
Wurde irgendwie jener vorgestellt und ist dann eben im Februar begutachtet worden. Ähm Begutachtung ging,
glaube bis zum achtundzwanzigsten Februar, wir haben unsere Stellungnahme am Tag davor eingebracht.
Es waren am Tag davor achtzehn Stellungnahmen schon auf der Parlamentsboxeite gelistet und irgendwie so äh ich glaub.
Ähm aber äh das Ding ist äh auf jeden Fall dann äh sozusagen
Mitternacht endet der Begutachtung, nächster Tag acht Uhr früh. Das Gesetz ist schon irgendwie nach der Begutachtung als also Regierungsvorlage ins Parlament gekommen. Man hat dann auch gesagt, wir haben uns,
achtzehn Stellungnahmen angeschaut. Es sind über vierundzwanzig eingelangt, eben noch am letzten Tag der Begutachtung. Unsere Warnnummer neunzehn
Also wir haben's klappt nicht geschafft. Ähm und äh jetzt ist äh dieses Gesetz eben als Regierungsverlag auf dem Weg ins Parlament, dort wird es ähm äh Landesverteidigungsausschuss äh behandelt, der
tagt aber erst im Juni und äh ja, dann wird man sehen, ob ähm
wie gesagt, Clubzwang, also äh eine Fraktionsdisziplin gibt's in Österreich sehr stark. Deswegen äh ist äh ist fraglich, ob da noch groß was geändert wird, aber es ist sozusagen jetzt auf dem Weg auch wirklich ein Gesetz zu werden.
Und äh die Begleitmusik ist, dass auch insgesamt gerade für das Bundesherr in Österreich mehr Geld ausgegeben wird. Wir haben einen FPÖ Verteidigungsminister und äh da wird jetzt aufgerüstet,
und eben auch mit neuen Kompetenzen das ganze komplementiert.
Sehr schön, das ist ja erfreulich. Also diese.
Militarisierung des Cyberspaces, ja äh des des Internets, das ist natürlich auch eine geradezu so, wenn man gerade an dreißig Jahre World White Web denkt und an die Verheißungen.
Die wir in dieser schönen Welt vor zehn, zwanzig Jahren so gefeiert und genossen haben, dann gehört auch das eben zu den.
Leider sehr traurigen ähm Entwicklungen, die wir zu beklagen haben in unserer schönen kleinen äh in unseren schönen kleinen Datennetz hier, was wir uns auf diesen, um diesen kleinen.
Die militärische Logik aufs Netz zu übertragen funktioniert halt
genauso wenig wie irgendwie äh die die Logik des Urheberrechts auf einen Filter zu übertragen. Das das skaliert nicht, dass das passt im Einzelfall nicht. Ähm du kannst da nicht irgendwie mit mehr Panzern
draufschießen und es wird besser, sondern machst es einfach nur für alle unsicherer. Und dass die Politik das in diesem Sailand immer noch nicht begriffen hat, das wird ihr so dermaßen mal auf den Kopf fallen.
Ähm.
Also ich denke, wenn du jetzt wirklich sagst, so wie Computersysteme, das ist halt einfach zu.
Ja, es wird der Sache auch nicht gerecht, also die die.
Da hast du ja einfach äh da steckt zu viel drin, worüber du dir Gedanken machen musst, wenn du auch nur
einmal irgendwie in die Praxis schaust und dir überlegst, okay, was, was für Macht gebe ich jetzt auch dieser ähm.
Dieser Säule der Gesellschaft, Militär ist ja doch irgendwie was anderes als der ganze Rest. Gibt ohne gut mit gutem Grund,
diese Trennung zwischen zivilen und militärischen Bereich und dann gerade in diesem super heikel militärischen Bereich, der nochmal irgendwie mehr Gewaltmonopol als die Polizei hat,
diese Logik auf eine Technik zu übertragen, die,
nicht abgrenzbar ist, weil das sind alles die selben Betriebssysteme, die wir verwenden. Es sind
überall die die selben Protokolle, die gesprochen werden, dasselbe Netz über das diese Daten laufen
und es ist ja nicht so, dass der Cyberkrieg nur von einer Kaserne gegen die andere geführt wird, sondern wenn jetzt gerade in Venezuela die der Strom ausfällt, weil das Wasserkraft ausfällt, weiß man halt,
war das jetzt gerade ein Cyber-Angriff von irgendjemanden oder haben die einfach die Main Tinance nicht gemacht? Das ist halt so ein ganz heikler Bereich, der auch ganz viel mit Zweifel und Kontrollverlust
tun hat. Frank hat das gut beschrieben. Äh wie er bei euch war und in seinem Buch. Also
da äh das Buch, was er mit Konstanze geschrieben hat. Da glaube ich, äh ist hat wirklich die, die grundsätzliche ja das grundsätzliche Verständnis viele einfach.
Wir bleiben nochmal beim Cyberrohr, den.
Was ja auch sehr spannend äh das äh uns die ganze Zeit beschäftigt. Wir verfolgen das hier im Logbuch eigentlich seit Beginn amüsiert, ist.
Im Prinzip der Wirtschaftskrieg zwischen USA und China.
Ähm der in den immer lauter werdenden Forderungen sich auch zeigt, man möge doch bitte.
Technik von Huawei nicht verwenden. Ich habe das hier im Logbuch schon ähm oft genug gesagt, dass unsere Netze bereits bis zu einem Drittel aus äh Huawei Komponenten bestehen
Ähm wir haben zumindest für Huawei Komponenten keine Erkenntnisse, dass sie.
Von dem chinesischen Geheimdienst in irgendeiner Form äh manipuliert werden oder äh zugreifbar sind oder da Kooperationen bestehen. Von anderen Komponenten wissen wir das
Insbesondere von US-amerikanischen Komponenten, die wir hier gerne und mit Freude ähm verbauen.
Und diese Warnung vor Huawei Komponenten, das äh habe ich übrigens jetzt mal sehr positiv wahrgenommen.
Bin sehr häufig zu diesem Thema gefragt worden von Mitarbeitern des Deutschen Bundestages von,
äh Journalistinnen und Journalisten von Menschen, die mit dem Thema irgendwie befasst sind. Ich habe im Prinzip immer, wie immer das Gleiche gesagt.
Also wir haben hier keine Anhaltspunkte dafür, dass das der Fall ist und wenn es so wäre, dann hätten
Problem ohnehin schon. Ja, das macht jetzt es wird in auf absehbare Zeit, wird die kritische Infrastruktur in Deutschland eher
vor allem für Zivilistinnen und Zivilisten. Äh wichtige äh Infrastruktur, eher das drei G vier G Netz sein oder sogar zwei G äh Netze als das fünf G Netz.
Bis das äh zum großen Problem wird für irgendwie eine kriegerische Auseinandersetzung, ein Spielnagel, Auseinandersetzung mit.
China oder so, ja? Da vergeht noch einige Zeit. Ähm.
Interessanterweise scheint es dieses Mal wirklich angekommen zu sein, was wir dazu sagen, denn ich äh hörte letztens den Patrick Sensburg.
Deutschlandfunk, der dann auch sagte.
Ja, wenn der, wenn das alles so schlimm ist mit den chinesischen Komponenten, dann würde ich jetzt auch gerne mal sehen, ja, wenn wenn das alles so gefährlich ist und wir das nicht zum Einsatz bringen sollen, dann äh liefert doch mal die Information, dass äh was es da gibt
ne, wenn ihr da Anhaltspunkte habt, wäre es doch spitze, wenn ihr die mit euren äh befreundeten.
Spionen, die wir ja nun mal in Deutschland sind, äh, teilen würdet.
Interessanterweise führte das dazu oder fiel diese Äußerungen im Kontext, dass der.
US-Botschafter Grenau, den wir hier in den ähm in Berlin dulden. Ähm.
Offenbar inzwischen relativ unverhohlen mit einer mit einem Einstellen der Geheimdienstzusammenarbeit droht.
Wenn Deutschland nicht den Einsatz von Whaway Komponenten.
Verhindern würde oder ja, also bin ich fassungslos eigentlich, was das was das für ein ähm.
Was das für eine Forderung ist. Genauso fassungslos bin ich übrigens. Gibt da jetzt irgendwie so eine neue Richtlinie.
Wo gesagt wurde, ja, wir haben jetzt irgendwie äh eine Richtlinie für den sicheren mit erhöhten Sicherheitsanforderungen für für die Systeme, wo irgendwie so ein,
Quatsch drin steht, der längst Tatsache ist, ja, dass sie irgendwie sagen, ja die die Hersteller müssen ähm,
ausreichend Mischung äh die die Netzbetreiber müssen ausreichend mischen, damit sie nicht übermäßig abhängig von einem Zulieferer werden.
Ja, als wenn die das nicht ohnehin machen würden, also ich
Diese, also Mobilfunknetze werden üblicherweise von, sagen wir mal bis zu vier Zulieferern
gebaut, aber jeder hat mindestens drei in Deutschland, ja? Wo du also Komponenten hast von dem einen Zulieferer, von dem anderen äh Zulieferer, um natürlich im Zweifelsfall die Gegenseite die ganze Zeit gegeneinander ausspielen zu können.
Ähm der eine ist also äh teurer, der andere ist äh billiger oder so, dass du die dann irgendwie gegeneinander.
Ähm also gegeneinander in irgendeiner Weise äh in Stellung bringen kannst.
Also da werden jetzt Vorgaben gemacht, die längst gelebte Praxis sind. Ich verstehe dieses gesamte Theater nicht. Und wenn jetzt auch noch
Botschafter anfängt,
Das deutsche Wirtschaftsministerium zu erpressen, dann wissen wir doch wirklich langsam, äh woher hier der Wind weht. Ich habe auch gleichzeitig gesagt, ich fände es natürlich als europäischer Bürger begrüßenswert, wenn diese Technologie,
aus Europa kommt. Von Europäern gebaut wird und wir versuchen nicht ganz den Anschluss zur Welt zu verlieren.
Das ist aber eben ein anderes Thema als eines der Sicherheit. Und deswegen finde ich es sehr interessant, dass da selbst.
Patrick Sensburg widerspricht und auch das Wirtschaftsministerium mehr oder weniger dem Herrn Grünau äh zu Verstehen gegeben hat, dann würden wir gerne mal sehen.
Also ich finde das so lustig, weil wie du sagst, äh im Grunde alle
könnten sich drauf eindecken, dass wir ähm diese Technik auch in Europa wieder produzieren wollen. Da gab es jetzt irgendwie Prozesshersteller sind oder eben Netzwerkequipment, aber es passiert ja nicht und wieso wird das eigentlich nicht schaffen, obwohl es äh einen starken Konsens dafür gibt, dass.
Naja, es gibt schon europäische Hersteller von Mobilfunkequipment, so ist das nicht. Die kommen ja auch zum Einsatz.
Richtung Alcatell und so sind die noch ähm Geschäft bei den Bereichen.
Na ja, du hast Nokia Siemens, Networks, du hast Eriksson, die sind schon also diese Geräte gibt es schon, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht genau, wie das äh mit ähm
mit fünf G im Moment ist, wie die da inzwischen aufgestellt sind. Das kann ich dir leider nicht genau sagen, weil ich mit fünf G nichts mehr zu tun habe.
Aber spannend finde ich ja auch einen Aspekt, dass wir jetzt sagen, so, dann stellen wir die Geheimdienstkooperation ein. Äh da würde ich.
Heiß, ja?
Ja? Also,
ihr macht mal. Das kam so oft auch bei Snowden als Argument, so äh da haben sie diesen riesigen Hebel die Kooperation einzustellen und ich glaube, dass da viel zu viel reininterpre,
wird in die wirklich den realen Effekt dieser.
Kooperation, was uns wirklich sicher macht und dass das halt einfach auch so ein Totschlagargument ist
manchmal verwendet wird bei bei großen Staaten gegenüber kleinen Staaten und in Wirklichkeit kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das so einen riesen Unterschied macht, vor allem eben USA versus Europa. Ich glaube
die inouropäische Kooperation ist bei der angesichts der Reisefreiheit, die wir hier haben. Die Freizügigkeit
äh von Personen und Wagen. Schon ein sehr starker Punkt.
Lass es mir noch eher einreden, aber über den Atlantik hinüber ähm würde ich gerne mal wissen, ob das wirklich stimmt, was immer ähm verlautbart wird.
Die sollen, also ich halte das für total. Quatsch, ehrlich gesagt. Na ja.
Also ich fänd's ja super, wenn die nicht mehr mit denen ihre Geheimdienstdaten teilen würden, ja. Tun ja fast so, als würde dann hier irgendwie eine Terrorwelle über uns hereinschwappen. Kann doch gar nicht, wir haben doch Upload-Filter.
Es kann doch gar nichts passieren mehr hier. Chelsea Mening.
Gerade noch von von Obama begnadigt, kann keine zwei Jahre her sein oder ungefähr zwei Jahre her. Ähm
Wir erinnern uns zweitausendzehn hat sie äh einige geheime Militärunterlagen weitergegeben, wurde noch im selben Jahr dafür angeklagt ähm und,
zu fünfunddreißig Jahren Gefängnis verurteilt? Weil sie Adrian Lemo verraten hatte.
Also Adian Adrian Lemo hatte sie verraten und.
Barack Obama hat sie dann kurz vor Ende seiner Amtszeit begnadigt, so dass sie seit ungefähr zwei Jahren wieder frei herumlaufen
durfte. Jetzt sollte sie vor ein Geheimgericht geladen werden. Äh eine Untersuchung des US-Justizministeriums über Wiki Leagues ähm
und die auf der Plattform veröffentlichten militärischen Dokumente klar so eine Veröffentlichung.
Zieht Ermittlungen nach sich und da sollte sie eben zu einer Befragung bitteschön erscheinen vor einer Grandury und das wäre irgendwie geheim gewesen. Und als sie gesagt, nee, machen wir nicht und jetzt ist sie ihm beugerhaft.
Und zwar bis sie ähm entweder mit sich mit dieser Grand Jury unterhält oder bis die Beweisaufnahme.
Da beendet ist und dieser Prozess beendet ist. Das ist auch echt naja, also sie ist nicht hingegangen mit der Begründung,
Ich habe zweitausenddreizehn bereits detailliert dazu schriftliche Angaben vor Gericht gemacht. Meine Erinnerung ist inzwischen nicht besser geworden. Und zweitens äh habe ich was gegen dieses Geheimgericht, weil ich denke, Justiz sollte in der Öffentlichkeit stattfinden.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Ähm ist schon krass, ne, dass du also dass sie.
Ihr das antun, dass sie das sich gibt, ja, dass sie.
Da immer noch standhaft ist. Äh bin mal sehr gespannt, wie das ausgeht. Sie könnte bis zu achtzehn Monate plus weitere sechs Monate als Strafe äh.
Einsitzen dafür, das heißt potentiell.
Zwei Jahre, sie kann aber natürlich jetzt Rechtsmittel einlegen das wird ihr Anwaltsteam natürlich machen und kann man sehen ob sie da unter Umständen halt ob das rechtens ist oder nicht.
Ja, also ich
bin wirklich beeindruckt von der Energie dieser Frau. Ähm wie viel die schon bewegt hat, ähm weil jemand die ist ja auch irgendwie, nachdem sie aus letztem Mal aus dem Gefängnis freigelassen wurde
nicht stillgeblieben, sondern hat äh ist er dann in Maryland. Äh ich glaube für den Senat hat sie kandidiert als
Unabhängiger, dritter Kandidat, ich glaube, Mary Land ist doch da, wo, dass die NSA-Zentrale ist. Äh was sind sie? Starker Bootmove ist und ähm
ich habe, ich habe sie ein paar Mal auf Konferenzen gesehen und ich glaube schon, dass das ähm Mensch ist, der sehr getrieben ist und daran wissentlich, wie
es innerhalb dieser Gefängnisse zugeht sich nochmal drauf einzulassen aufgrund einer Werturteils, dass man einfach sagt, Justiz muss bitte öffentlich sein und nein, ich kooperiere hier nicht und gehe dafür ins Gefängnis. Das ist schon
eine enorme Leistung. Ähm.
Wir verlinken dazu auch noch auf Netzpolitik Orges, gibt auch die Adresse. Man kann ihr Briefe schreiben ähm und ich glaube, es gibt hier auch noch eine Petition,
X-White Chelsea
ähm also der Fall ist auf jeden Fall ähm noch nicht vorbei ähm und ein ruhiges Privatleben sei ihr noch nicht vergönnt scheinbar.
Womit wir beim letzten Thema werden.
Gute Nachrichten, ganz zuletzt.
Ist es eine gute Nachricht, halb, ne? Ist eine halb gute Nachricht. Ähm,
soll eine Whisleblower-Richtlinie geben, die Wizle Blowerin wie Chelsea Meding oder auch denjenigen, die die Panama-Papers oder die Looks Leaks uns gebracht haben.
Rechtlich besser schützt. Ähm wenn sie.
Rechtswidrige Vorgänge an die Öffentlichkeit bringen und dabei selber rechtswidrig handeln. Natürlich ähm.
Forderte Deutschland hier einen deutlich schwächeren Schutz, ja. Katharina Barley als Justizministerin hat ähm.
Sich im Rat dafür eingesetzt, dass Whisleblower sich immer zuerst einer eine interne Stelle in der eigenen Organisation wenden müssen,
Bevor sie Informationen nach außen geben dürfen,
Was auch geil ist. Anonymes Whislebloing nur noch nach vorheriger Anmeldung und ähm das
kann man sich natürlich vorstellen, das hätte wahrscheinlich sehr viele Whisleblower abgeschreckt und wenn man sich irgendwie anschaut, was da so bei Moslek von CK los war, das hätte ich auch sehr witzig gefunden, wenn da so hallo äh ich,
Ich würde gerne äh was Visselblon, nämlich was wir hier machen ist eine riesige Scheißschweinerei. Das ganze Unternehmen ist einfach nur gebaut, um
andere zu betrügen. Ja wissen wir. Äh steht auch vorne dran.
Okay so dann also das ist das wäre wirklich 'ne geniale Idee, ja? Dass dass wenn,
verpflichtet sich vorher im eigenen Unternehmen zu melden. Glücklicherweise hat das selbst in diesem Kontext nicht den Lachtest bestanden, denn.
Es wurde ein Kompromiss erzieht, denn nun lautet das Hinweisgeber sich mit Berichten über Missbestände äh Missstände, unter bestimmten Bedingungen direkt an die zuständigen Behörden wenden dürfen, zum Beispiel.
Wenn sie Vergeltungsmaßnahmen fürchten müssen.
Muss man ja nicht mit rechnen, als wusste blauer Vergeltungsmaßnahmen. Wieso? Denn ja. Und ähm.
Auch links an die Medien sind in einigen Fällen dann rechtlich geschützt. Die der komplette Text der Einigung lag aber zum Redaktionsschluss noch nicht vor, weil Lokboden Netzpolitik. Deswegen sind wir mal gespannt.
Wie das dann an äh an das an das Parlament zur endgültigen Verabschiedung geschickt wird. Aber es sieht so aus, dass wir wenigstens nach,
dem Wisserblowing und Leaking und diese ganzen Sachen tatsächlich so als Phänomen dann doch seit über zehn Jahren eigentlich dieses ganze netzpolitische auch sehr begleiten. Ähm.
Dass man sich jetzt endlich mal darum bemüht, da auch was Positives dran zu erkennen, ne.
Ja, das.
Und das auch mal zu schütz.
Genau, also ich ich finde das auch eine eine Leistung und eigentlich doch äh bin
äh froh, dass sich Europa dadurch gerungen hat, äh so eine Richtlinie zu machen, weil das Phänomen wissen, bloggen haben wir jetzt doch schon irgendwie
seit bei zehn Jahren diskutiert und das ist ein wichtiges Instrument in einer Gesellschaft, das ist so das Überdruckventil, wenn's gar nicht mehr geht und äh dass man da für diese Menschen, die oft irgendwie leben
oder zumindest ihre Existenz aufs Spiel setzen, um Missstände aufzudecken, so einen minimalen Schutz etabliert äh,
das ist schon gut und vor allem ähm
im, im Hinblick auf äh die östlichen äh europäischen Länder und vielleicht auch, äh, ich meine, ich find's lustig, dass sich Deutschland hier im Rat quer gestellt hat. Ähm, äh, eigentlich hätte ich da eher an andere Länder gedacht, wo man
da mehr Widerstand hätte, aber an sich.
Ich glaube, die haben halt einfach Angst um die Autoindustrie, ne? Weil da also.
Da könnte ein Whistleblower, könnte der deutschen Autoindustrie gut tun, ja?
Ja, aber irgendwann kommt das ja raus. Also es hilft ja nichts. Das ist, das ist sehr kurzfristig gedacht. Ähm ich äh glaube schon, dass man da schneller besser fahren würde, wenn man das einfach auslässt. Aber gut.
Damit werden wir denke ich bei den Terminen.
Ja die erste ähm Meldung hier ist,
Anrufparty in Berlin und zwar am Donnerstag den einundzwanzigsten März von elf bis achtzehn Uhr in der Seebase. Äh Anrufpartys äh eben um.
Pletsch oder andere Tröstabgeordnete zu kontaktieren. Kann man überall machen, kostet nicht viel, aber gemeinsam anrufen ist lustiger. Ja und
Dann haben wir noch eine Action Week zum Urheberrecht von Edri. Ähm Etri hatte eine ganze Reihe an Aktivit.
Ähm mehr oder weniger von äh zwanzigsten äh März beginnend bis zur Abstimmung am sechsundzwanzigsten März zum Urheberrecht, zu Uploadfiltern. Da könnt ihr euch beteiligen auf unterschiedlichste Arten
ähm und eben auch, wenn ihr wollt, wie schon mal erwähnt, äh, die Reisekosten ersetzen lassen, falls ihr nach Brüssel oder Straßburg
kommen wollt, um dort mit Abgeordneten zu sprechen und die vielleicht noch zu überzeugen. Äh, muss man sich melden, ist ein Auswahlverfahren
also vielleicht zuerst irgendwie schauen, ob man das kriegt, bevor man bucht, aber Brüssel Straßburg seht ihr nicht weit weg und man kann dort auf jeden Fall auch nochmal gelebte Demokratie ähm erfahren, indem man selber durchs Parlament,
und mit Abgeordneten Termine ausmacht und die versucht zu überzeugen.
Und schon erwähnt natürlich am dreiundzwanzigsten März auch noch die Demos in zweiundvierzig Städten in ganz Europa.
Zweiundvierzig Städten, eine Güte. Okay, damit sind wir tatsächlich.
Am Ende der Sendung angelangt. Ich werde ja nächste Woche.
Mal schauen wie die Sendung wird, wenn wir es schaffen. Ich werde ja auch mal nach Brüssel fahren, um dann nach dem Rechten zu sehen, mir scheint.
Die haben sich da irgendwie nicht im Griff.
Und sehe nach dem Rechten. Wir werden uns da wahrscheinlich sogar dann persönlich treffen, Thomas.
Aber ob wir das hinkriegen dann auch zu Podcasten werden wir sehen unsere Terminkalender sind auf jeden Fall voll.
Rekord, wir gehen Bier trinken und Waffeln essen und in Brüssel kommen die Leute zusammen. Zu viel ist sicher.
Und dann sind wir an dem Teil der Sendung, wo ich immer noch einmal danke und da danke ich dieses Mal vor allem dem Tim und ich muss weiß, dass ich hier seit einigen Wochen einer.
Ähm weiteren Personen Dankschulde. Ich weiß aber leider nicht wem.
Deswegen wenn du deinen Namen hier in dieser Liste vermisst, dann würde ich mich freuen, wenn du dich kurz mal bei mir melden würdest. Das geht über das Kontaktformular.
Auf meiner Webseite. Es bleibt spannend im Internet.
Und somit auch bei Lokbuchnetzpolitik und ich würde sagen.
Genug gute und schlechte Nachrichten für heute. Wir haben's geschafft, eine halbwegs kurze Sendung zu machen und deswegen wollen wir die am Ende jetzt auch gar nicht ausfasern lassen, sondern verabschieden uns sehr freundlich.
Auf die nächsten dreißig Jahre. Bis bald.
Bis bald, ciao ciao.